When you're preparing for an interview in the field of autonomous systems,
it's important to remember that the questions you'll consider in
this course are just one piece of the puzzle.
Just as important, is the need to know data structures and algorithms and often C++.
A typical interview in
autonomous systems will likely include questions from both of these areas.
C++ is often crucial for these types of positions to the most applications,
Mean Embedded Systems, limited resources.
A drone and even a car can only fit so much compute power on board.
Latency would often be too high to rely on cloud compute here.
Certain positions or companies may let you get by an only Python,
such as a role iterating and deep learning models but,
if you work directly on a robot, you'll need C++.
We have a separate course for C++ technical interviews
as well as material or some useful data structures and algorithms to know.
You can find the lead in the instructor's notes below
and we'll also have additional resources at the end of the course.